everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem cheapest flights
within k stops i think this is a really
good interview question because there's
so many different ways to solve this
problem and there's a lot of different
trade-offs that you can discuss the main
way that i'm actually going to be
solving this problem is by using the
bellman ford algorithm which is an
algorithm that we haven't really gone
over on this channel before so i think
this is a good opportunity to go over it
so to explain the problem this is
obviously a graph problem as you can see
from the picture where given a bunch of
nodes each node represents a city and
each edge in the graph represents
obviously they are directed edges as you
can see from the arrow down here so each
edge represents a flight that connects
two cities together for example city
zero and city one are connected together
meaning we can go from city zero down to
city one we can travel along this flight
and the edge actually does have a weight
so in this case it's a hundred so that
represents the cost or the price to go
from city zero to city one and we're
asked a very simple question we're given
a source node in this case city 0 and a
destination node in this case city 2.
we're asked a simple question of what is
the cheapest price traveling from city
zero to city 2 the only catch here is
that we can only do at most k stops so
that's really the catch of this problem
because as you know we know an algorithm
that can calculate shortest paths right
even with weighted edges this algorithm
can can calculate shortest paths and
it's called jigstra's algorithm but we
can't use it easily in this problem
because we're given a condition of at
most k stops so if we try to take that
idea and then incorporate it into
gixxer's algorithm it's not super
efficient but it is still doable but
there's another algorithm that also
calculates shortest paths and that is
called the bellman ford algorithm and
with this shortest path algorithm we can
incorporate the idea of at most k stops
and also do it efficiently the overall
time complexity is actually going to be
let's say e where e is the number of
edges and k is the input parameter that
we're given at most k stops the way it's
going to work is it's going to be
similar to a breath first search
approach in general though the bellman
ford algorithm actually runs an e times
v time where v is the number of vertices
e is the number of edges but in this
case we're given a condition of k so the
time complexity in this case is just
going to be e times k and by the way
looking at this problem what is the
solution well obviously we have a direct
edge linking zero to two obviously the
cost is 500 in that case but we do have
a second path if we go all the way to
one costs a hundred and then we go from
one to two then another hundred so that
in total is going to be 200 not too bad
right this is shorter like i mean the
price is smaller and this does fit
within our criteria obviously this path
how many stops did this path have you
might think it's two because we had we
traveled along two different edges but
when we say stops we're just calculating
what's the number of cities between the
starting point and the destination there
was only one city in between them so
that means we did fit the criteria of
down here we were given k equals one we
can only have one at most one stop in
between the source uh and the
destination so we were we did fit that
criteria so in this case the result is
gonna be 200 because this path is a
valid path so now let's try to
understand how bellman ford algorithm
can actually help us so now let's try to
understand the bellman ford algorithm
and just to give you a little bit of a
background on bellman ford it's actually
a pretty general algorithm there's
different implementations of it one of
the benefits of bellman ford is that it
can actually deal with the negative
weights which is something jigstra's
algorithm can't deal with but in this
case obviously we don't have negative
weights so what we're going to be
focusing on is what we actually need
from the bellman ford algorithm to solve
this problem so we do have a source node
a in this case and we have a destination
node c in this case so the main idea
with this algorithm is to start at the
source node a so in this case this node
and then slowly do a breath first search
right so from a first we would look at
what's the first layer of nodes that we
can reach within one stop right within
one stop okay we can reach
b
and c and then we'd continue that
breadth first search and say okay now
within two stops how many different
nodes can we reach well can't really go
anywhere from here can't go anywhere
from here but from here we can go to
this uh position c and in doing this
breadth first search we're going to
simultaneously be keeping track of for
each node that we have visited or can
visit what is the minimum price that it
takes to reach that node because
remember that's what we're trying to
solve we're trying to find from starting
at a going to see what's the minimum
cost it would take within k stops so
that's something i didn't mention yet in
this case we have k equals one right so
since k equals one what's the breadth
first search going to be does that mean
we're only going to do one layer of
breadth first search no we're actually
going to be doing k
plus one layers of breadth first search
and that's that has nothing to do with
bellman ford that just has to do with
how this problem is defined they just
define to us that we can do at most k
stops between the starting position and
the destination right so this would be
one stop between these two nodes so
you're probably wondering why do i have
this second temporary array of prices
i'll get more into that in a moment for
now i would just kind of focus on the
general idea of what we're doing so if
we're doing a breadth first search and
we're starting at a what's the cost the
minimum cost from starting at a to reach
a well it's going to be zero of course
right and so far if we've only reached a
what's the minimum cost to reach b and c
we're just going to put that as infinity
for now so now we're going to do the
breadth first search portion but the
thing about this breadth for search is
it's not implemented how you would think
we're not just going to look at a and
only look at the neighbors of a we're
actually going to go through every
single edge in this graph so for example
let's go at the first edge okay this
edge has a weight of 100 it connects a
to node b so now the question is we can
reach b along this edge did we find a
new minimum path to be able to reach
this node b
did we or did we not well as of right
now the value is infinity we found a way
to reach node b with what's the cost to
reach node b it's whatever the cost is
to reach node a right which we already
know is zero right so we're gonna say
zero plus whatever the weight of this
edge is which is a hundreds right so the
overall cost to reach node b is a
hundred that's less than infinity which
is what we have so we can get rid of
this infinity and then put a hundred
but when we update this value we're not
going to update it in the original
prices array we're going to update it in
the temporary prices array and then once
we've completely updated the temporary
prices array we're going to go ahead and
put all of the values in the new prices
array so we went over this edge already
now let's look at another edge let's
take a look at this edge 500. it
connects a to c right so how much did it
take to reach node a we know that's
already zero right okay so going from
node a which costs 0 to get to plus 500
which is this edge to get to c so it so
we found a way to get to node c with a
cost of 500. is this smaller than the
current minimum that we have for c which
is infinity yes it's smaller so we can
replace this with infinity but of course
we're going to do it in the temporary
prices array next we're going to look at
this third and final edge even though
this edge is not connected to a right i
said this was a breath for search but i
guess it's not technically a breadth
first search because we are looking at
all edges but notice what's going to
happen when we look at this edge okay we
found a way to go from node b to get to
node c and it costs a hundred to do that
did we find a new minimum to get to node
c well the first question is how what's
the cost to actually get to b to get to
b is infinity it's not 100 100 is what
we determined but for now we're going to
be using this original value i'll
explain why in a moment it takes a
infinity to get to node b so to get to
node c takes infinity plus 100 that's
not smaller than infinity right so any
time we get to an infinity in the source
node right so we took a look at this
edge right this is the source this is
the destination it took in it took
infinity to get to the source so we're
just going to skip this edge all
together right so it technically is a
breath first search because we're
skipping edges that we haven't actually
gotten to for the source node and
there's a lot of like technical
questions you could probably ask so why
am i even you know implementing it this
way why am i going through all the edges
when i could just do a regular breath
for search the main reason is because
the time complexity is not actually
going to change and doing it this way is
a lot easier to code you're going to be
surprised how short the code is when i
actually show that to you and to be
honest since the overall time complexity
is the same i think it's much better to
go with a readable solution rather than
a solution that saves you maybe 10 on
the runtime right so i think this is one
of the cases where simplicity is much
better than a slight improvement in
performance this is our temporary prices
array and by the way we are going to
have this zero here so
if we updated a value in this case we
did then we put the values here or the
original values will still be there so
what did we discover what does this
array represent and what does this array
represent basically before we started
our breadth for search this is what we
had now we've done a breadth first
search of one layer and this is what
we've determined for the sh for the
smallest price to pay to reach each of
these nodes this is what we've done so
far for one layer but how many layers
are we going to do in this case k is one
does that mean we're only going to do
one layer nope remember what i said
we're going to do k plus one layers i
know that's kind of confusing but it's
just kind of how the problem is set up
okay so now we're going to do our last
layer of the bfs by the way i replaced
our prices with this and temp prices
will stay the same temp prices is always
just going to be a copy of the regular
prices and then when we update values
we're going to put the updated values
here then you know reassign them up here
and then continue that kind of loop and
of course we're going to do this k plus
1 times right that's how the breadth for
search is going to work we're going to
update this entire array k plus 1 times
so basically if the input value was k
equals zero we have that result right
within zero stops uh this would be the
minimum cost to reach the destination
node c 500 but we know k is actually one
so we can have one stop in between the
source and the destination so now once
again we're gonna do the exact same
thing we're just gonna go through every
single edge so let's look at this first
edge okay we know that from going from a
to b it takes a hundred right so how
much does it take to get to a it takes
0. so it takes 0 plus 100 to get to b is
that smaller than what we have for b no
it's the exact same which is what we
expect right we know within one stop or
we know within zero stops in between it
takes 100 to get there so having an
extra stop in between a and b doesn't
decrease that is what we found right if
you have two stops three stops four
stops between a and b it doesn't reduce
the cost it's always going to be a
hundred so this value will stay the same
in temp prices let's look at the next
edge this is going to be the exact same
thing right 500 is just going to be the
vowel that we put here it's already the
same increasing the number of stops does
not decrease the cost to get to c
at least along this edge but now we're
going to look at the third and final
edge this edge and it takes from b to
get to c takes 100 how much does it take
to get to b it takes 100 to get to b
right so 100 plus the value of this edge
100 is 200 right 200 is what it takes to
get to c now so is this 200 smaller than
what we currently have for c yes it is
that means we can update the value in
temp prices for c we can change this 500
to a 200 sorry if it's not readable i'd
put it over here but 200 is the cost to
reach c if we add an extra stop in
between so now that we've gone through
every single edge again we're going to
take all of these put the values up here
and we're actually done with the loop
we're done with the entire algorithm
because we ran it k plus 1 times so
since this 200 since this 500 up here is
going to be a 200 right that means 200
is the value that we're going to return
for the entire result right within one
stop in between a and c which is
obviously this route over here it takes
200 cost to get there uh just an fyi if
we were not actually able to reach this
right like maybe within k stops we
actually can't even go from a to the
destination c what would we return in
that case would we just return infinity
no the way the problem is written they
just want us to return negative one if
that's ever the case so i hope this
algorithm makes sense and i hope you can
see why the time complexity is e times k
because the loop is going to run k times
and every time we loop we're going to be
iterating through every single edge in
the graph which is e so this is where
the time complexity comes from you're
probably still wondering why exactly do
we have this temporary prices array if
you're not you can probably skip ahead a
minute but if you are let me explain
that to you suppose we change the
problem slightly suppose instead of
having k equals one we change it to k
equals zero that means the loop is going
to run k plus 1 times that means the
loop is going to run exactly one time so
let's see what happens in that case what
would be the output in that case if we
could only have zero stops in between a
and c what's going to be the cost to
reach node c of course it's going to be
500 right there's only one possible way
we can reach c from a if we have zero
stops in between we can't go along this
path on the left side because it has one
stop in between we're only allowed zero
stops in between so if we run the
algorithm and if we didn't have a
temporary prices array let me show you
what would happen we're going to go
through the first edge 100 right okay
we're going to figure out okay it takes
100 to get to b right so we can replace
this infinity with a hundred sorry if
it's not readable but this is 100. next
we're going to go to the second edge
right another hundred what are we gonna
say we're gonna say okay how long does
it take to reach b it takes infinity
nope it takes a hundred right because we
put that update simultaneously in the
exact same prices that we're iterating
through right we put a hundred here so
now what we're gonna say is okay how
many how much does it take to reach c a
hundred plus a hundred that it took to
reach node b so then we'd put a 200
value in the c spot right we'd put 200
over here but what we just did because
we updated the same prices we didn't
have a temporary prices what we did is
we instead used a path that had an extra
node along it and we weren't allowed to
do that look we had k equals zero so
that's the idea of why we have to use a
temporary prices array okay so now let's
code it up and the best part about
writing the code with my videos is i
spend so much time explaining the
solution that now writing the code is
gonna be pretty trivial i bet for most
of you so we're going to initialize
prices to be infinity right where how
how big is price is going to be it's
going to be the number of nodes that
we're given that parameter is n and
we're going to initialize it to all
infinity except for the source node
remember the source node we're going to
say it takes a price of 0 to get to the
source node and that's the only variable
we're going to need now we can actually
start iterating uh through the loop
remember how many times are we going to
iterate through the loop we're going to
do k plus one time so k is the input
parameter we can use that we can do this
loop k plus one times and once we do
that we're gonna go through every single
edge remember so uh edges are located in
the flights array so we're going to go
through every flight each flight or edge
has three values a source which i'm
going to say is s a destination which is
d right going from s to d each edge is
going to be directed each edge is also
going to have a price so p is going to
be what price is so iterating through
this flights array let me just put a
comment to tell you uh what each of
those variables means and remember
before we actually go through this loop
we do want to have a temporary prices
array and what we're how we're going to
initialize this temporary prices is just
going to be a copy of whatever prices
happens to be at this point in time so
just create a copy of prices this
temporary prices is where our updates
are going to go so there's only two
conditions we're going to check for
remember the one special case is if this
source node right we have an edge source
destination and price if this source
node
is not even possible to reach meaning if
the price located at the source node
happens to be infinity that that means
we can't even reach this source node if
it's equal to infinity so in that case
we're just going to continue the loop
right we don't want to check these edges
and the only other case that we're going
to look for is if we found a new
shortest path to the destination node d
so if we want to know what's the price
to actually reach the source node s so
far what's the minimum price to reach
the source node s we know it's
definitely not going to be infinity
because we just checked that up above so
whatever that price happens to be plus
whatever is the price of this particular
edge that we're iterating through so the
price to reach s plus this edge
connecting s with d so if this is
smaller than whatever the minimum price
is to reach the destination then we're
going to update that weight or or rather
we're going to update that price and
we're not going to be checking this
prices that way we're actually going to
be checking if it's smaller than the
temp prices array because it could be
possible that through this single loop
we updated this value already once right
this temporary prices array so if we
update it multiple times we want that
update to be reflected we want to we
want to just make sure that we're
getting the minimum value is what i'm
getting at so if it's smaller than that
then we're going to be
updating this to
be
this new minimum that we just found
right this happens to be smaller than
this so it's time to do an update so we
can just copy and paste this into uh
this line of code that's all for this
for loop so once we're done updating
those minimums uh the last thing we're
gonna have to do is take temporary
prices and then reassign it to be prices
so prices can be updated to
be just like this and really that is the
entire implementation of bellman ford at
least for the context of this problem we
don't need any min heaps or anything
like jigstr's algorithm and then finally
we can return the result what are we
going to return we're going to return
prices of d right we want to know the
minimum price to reach a destination
actually not d we're going to be using
dest because that's the input parameter
that we're given up above over here but
remember it could be infinity if it's
equal to infinity so let's say if
this is equal to float of infinity then
we actually want to return negative one
so return negative one if this condition
is true if this condition is not true
then we can just return whatever the
actual minimum price happens to be okay
so now let's run it to make sure that it
works it doesn't have an amazing run
time on leak code so you can see that it
does work and it's relatively efficient
you can make it slightly more efficient
i think if you use like a hash map and
stuff but i think for the most part and
especially for interviews that
definitely won't be a factor so i really
hope this was helpful i'm pretty sure
this is going to be a really long video
and it's going to probably be a pain to
edit so i do hope it was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon where you can
further support the channel and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon
thanks for watching